[Music]
welcome back to the joy of painting i'm
bob ross
the beauty of painting is you can paint
whatever you like
we can paint a landscape or a portrait
even this week let's go with something
topical
something in the news
secretary hillary rodham clinton has
been in the news a lot let's do that
for that you're going to need your paint
brush some colors you can use whatever
you like
i suggest
liquid whites
mucus green some slate colors and lots
of
more liquid whites lots of liquid whites
in the hillary clinton
campaign let's get started and draw the
secretary here let's paint the secretary
herself
little blonde there for her hair
not too blonde
not too blunt because it's not real
blonde
that you can add whatever you want let's
continue drawing the face
narrow shoulders
narrow shoulders and wide birthing hips
beautiful wide birthing hips with narrow
shoulders perfect
for carrying little chelsea
perfect for carrying little
little clinton's there see how it's
coming together very nicely
oh that's a beautiful hillary clinton
now
she's had some health scares recently
the secretary
let's draw a little bit of
she's coughing here
let's draw her coughing up some mucus
that's the mucus green i told you but
let's have some green there
oh
beautiful color it's unfortunate
sometimes it's associated with sickness
it's a beautiful color in its own right
and then she's been coughing pretty
badly let's draw a little lung
a little lung
that hillary clinton
the secretary expelled in her coughs
right there and see how that's coming
together she looks a little lonely
let's give her some trees
little happy trees there
little happy trees they don't have to be
complex
little happy trees but you know what
she needs more than trees this is
topical we can do something different
let's give her some bodies
let's just draw some little bodies
the clinton body count right there let's
draw a little body oh there's a vince
foster look at that she just beat the
devil out of him little bodies to keep
hillary company
now
let's go back to hillary herself since
we're filling this in she's had some
health scares
let's draw some shake lines here
her hands and head were shaking
from some kind of disease could be
parkinson's
could be cancer
epilepsy
you can pick whatever disease you like
that's the beauty of painting
aids
could be whatever disease you want to
draw for hillary clinton could be all of
them
she could have every disease under the
sun you know what
let's draw a sun
let's draw sun let's draw sun up here
nice warm yellow sun saying hello to the
secretary
beating down
because
it was hot in new york let's draw that
hot warm sun
beating down on hillary making her sick
creating a
sweltering
bone dry 74 degrees look at that
that's coming together nicely see
no doubt as to who that is
we have to finish this up here
with her sickness she needs some help
she needs some friends
let's draw her security detail
coming in right there her security
detail
now you can make them whatever color you
want they could be brown
or black
but let's be honest they're most likely
white let's draw them white
most of her security detail is going to
be liquid whites
there you go it's not
not her fault people have different
upbringing some people are afraid of
colored folk
they can be intimidating liquid whites
her security detail now to finish this
they're stabbing her with a diazepam pen
stopping the violent convulsions with a
diazepam pen
right there let's paint that stabbing
the secretary with a die as a pam pen so
she can feel all better
feeling all better look at that
painting doesn't have to be complicated
look at the beautiful picture we did
and that was a good warm up
with just her body double when we come
back
we'll paint the real thing
happy painting
and god bless you my friends
[Music]
i i feel i feel great really ready to
break through that glass ceiling stephen
oh good because you had a pretty serious
health scare this week that led a lot of
people to start questioning oh you know
you know as well as i knew that that's
just uh a right-wing conspiracy from the
the bag of deplorables that's good i can
tell you it's going to take a lot more
than uh simple allergies to keep hillary
rodham clinton down i thought it was
pneumonia